jerk-off in your office I've never done
it
what never I've jerked off at every
almost every other job of that
where are you like what's the big deal
are you worried advertising you're
blasting out of your ass what's the
big deal I look I agree I think there
should be jerk-off sweets I remember I
think that should be an option anytime I
have a jerk-off it's I it's like a
minute I have like 60 seconds Commission
someone just walks out to deliver a
cheese plate to the guests and you're
like oh pretty much yeah pretty much and
I think I have such a good marriage that
my wife that we know like we know so
like my wife will be like you're five
minutes you can jerk off if you want for
the Mimi downstairs because we have to
take old school shut you then has she
ever caught you at all billions of times
and do you stop are you like this is me
baby depends on uh that's when the
jerk-offs are different I've never been
like this is me baby you should be like
yeah I know we glass I might are you
we're in Texas Texas yeah say hell gig
that was a hell gig it felt like a rich
person's New Year's Eve party yes where
they had hired a bunch of comics to just
be there because I couldn't hear all I
could hear with a conversation yeah I
couldn't know I could hear like a mill I
think I heard like four people say they
were going to see childish gambino
I saw him later that night with you
sorry what we both went to see we're
super supportive yeah I know I I knew I
met Donald like he was eighteen and like
from the moment we hung out I was like
you're Eddie Murphy yeah the funniest
person I've ever met in my life yes
don't think he is yeah it's a shame I
think that people don't get to see it
because cuz because he's a music music
star but he to me is the funniest person
hands down I met I like that we said we
went to support him when there were like
48 teenage girls that would have cut off
my face to see the show oh yeah I want
to see him I went to like I stopped by
like backstage
to see him did you get in cuz I got a
text saying you were there from Nick
yet to get you well Nick and I didn't
actually get in at first and and I'm so
pumped I was gonna get an Xbox if I
showed up did they not give you an Xbox
they did but the doorman was like we're
at full capacity and not that he would
know anything but I was like I'm on my
xbox maybe they were giving out X bar
just like left and right I didn't get an
expert I saw like three South by
Southwest homeless people get Xbox I
want to walk into my room be like Xbox
on go Xbox five minutes jerk off Xbox is
like you have 30 seconds Adam pally
thank you as always coming back to the
show Pete it's always a pleasure
you're welcome anytime cool um do you
still need me to lend you money if I
could talk to you off camera was it
there again no one watches those we are
basically off